hi i'm derek downey a developer advocate
for google cloud i'm currently
developing a banking app that uses cloud
spanner and have previously discussed
setting up the instance database and
schema
in this final video i'm going to
highlight the two methods my banking app
can use to modify data in spanner
dml statements and spanner mutations
[Music]
in cloud spanner there are two ways to
modify data in an application
the first is data manipulation language
or dml
the second method is to use spanner
mutations
both dml and mutations are executed
within an acid transaction so changes
commit or roll back as an atomic unit
but which one should i use
let's take a look at each implementation
users of other sql-based systems will be
familiar with dml statements
these are insert update and delete
statements
because of this familiarity using dml
provides an easy transition for making
changes to spanner data
dml is further broken into standard dml
and partitioned dml
at a high level standard dml is great
for single statements while partition
dml is a special implementation for bulk
data changes
dml statements allow you to read your
rights so if you make a change to data
those changes are available to later
statements within the same transaction
and finally any constraints defined on
the schema are checked after each
statement within a transaction to ensure
data integrity for later statements in
that transaction
mutations are a sequence of inserts
updates or deletes that make changes to
specific rows or tables in a database
without using the sql layer but these
changes are still made within an acid
transaction
changes made by mutations are applied in
the order they are specified
these changes are buffered in the client
locally then sent to spanner to be
applied when the transaction is finished
because of this mutations do not support
read after write within the same
transaction
and constraints are checked at commit
time rather than after each mutation
so using dml or mutations depends on the
use case
here are some guidelines
dml statements are great for typical
oltp workload usage and have the benefit
of familiarity for anyone comfortable
with sql
for large change operations either use
mutations or partition dml
if you need to read changes from within
the same transaction or want constraints
to be checked after each statement then
use dml
if you want the ability to upsert you
will need to use mutations
in my banking app i am using dml to
create an account since it's a single
insert statement and i'm familiar with
the sql syntax but i use mutations to
update the account and enter the details
in the ledger because i do not need to
read the data within the transaction
after it changes
also because mutations are buffered
locally this larger transaction should
be more performant
both dml and mutations are supported in
the native spanner client libraries so
you can use the right method for
specific changes as i just showed
one caveat is that dml statements and
mutations should not be mixed within the
same transaction
this is because there might be some
unexpected results for mutations since
they are buffered until the commit of
the transaction
with the ability to write data to
spanner using dml and spanner mutations
my banking application is ready for the
next stage of development
this series has shown how to get started
developing against spanner quickly using
the emulator and how to size your
instance when you're ready to expand
development i discussed different
options to control database behavior for
performance availability and security in
the third video and in the fourth video
i went over the basics for designing a
schema to avoid hot spots and perform
efficient lookups taking into account
how spanner splits data to achieve great
scalability thank you for following
along in this journey to get my banking
application working on cloud spanner let
me know in the comments if there are
other spanner topics you'd like more
information on
otherwise what are you waiting for get
working on your own application for
cloud spanner today
[Music]
you